boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake I'm
very excited to still be at Co Fez the
Congress on the future of engineering
software for our second annual
partnership with them we are now sitting
down with Karen Kass Welch and dr.
Provine Yadav hello thank you for coming
on to the show hi how are you
we're very excited thank you yes yes
there's so much to talk about what
generative design and what you guys are
doing with SCI our software we're really
excited to unpack that for those that
don't know Praveen has been doing he's
been working his way up to the
co-founder and CTO role at SCI art
software three and a half years Karen
has been over a year now working her way
up into the CEO role and syrus doing
awesome work we're gonna be unpacking
that and what generative design actually
means before we get there let's learn
about your journeys how did you guys get
excited about engineering software and
teach us about your journey leading up
to this point I'll go first
why I am doing the engineering software
I started my career as a suspension
designer for Tata Motors this was back
in 2007 in July of 2007 and my problem
with being a designer was there weren't
any tools that would allow me to perform
analysis up for an analysis on the
designs that I wanted to create for the
vehicles that we were designing and as
expected my daily life was a lot of
hitting dead ends without knowing how to
sort of overcome them and there was a
separate analysis group that I had to
sort of communicate with to sort of help
me out with my design process so I quit
my job I wanted to be an analyst because
I liked that job better than my job so I
came to University of Wisconsin to
pursue my graduate studies specifically
sort of understand the simulation
engineering and then about six and a
half years into my PhD program we
created something that I thought would
be a very useful tool to the design
engineer who quit his job to come to
grad school and that
so I got involved in the side software
business so I have a slightly different
career path I have a mechanical
engineering degree and I mean I wanted
to change manufacturing so that was that
was my underlying I want to change
manufacturing and make it you know
successful in the United States so I
came to I went to General Motors and I
was at GM for 24 years mostly in the
manufacturing side so I ran the chassis
shift at a GM truck plant I I went to
Asia and then I was a VP of purchasing
for Allison Transmission and about 10
years ago I moved on from GM and ended
up running a software company and
started getting exposed to engineering
software now this was supply chain
product costing software but it did
interact on the engineering side so I I
have now been a member of I've run or
been number two in charge of four five
different startups and about a year year
and a half ago
pravin reached out and we started
talking to each other and I was really
interested in you know how to design for
the future and we I think generative
design is really a key for the future
whether it's for additive manufacturing
or traditional manufacturing and I was
so intrigued with what SIA art was doing
that I wanted to come and be a part of
the company in the journey
oh man the origin stories are all are
always very interesting there's so many
years of experience with your background
like 25 years or something of experience
is crazy
or so that's yeah that's that's amazing
and that's a lot to actually be able to
go and see all the processes and also
know the importance of what you're
working on now and Praveen I also really
enjoyed how you know when when you
actually do have this really serious
problem and you know that
something needs to fill this fill the
role and then to be able to build it and
go and bring it into the world
so now let's let's let's talk about this
alright we we find ourselves as probably
you know manufacturing like on a big
history perspective manufacturing now
more than ever
we're just producing so many different
complex goods we're designing them we're
engineering them all the way this
product lifecycle management all the way
from idea until its disposal or
recycling so as as a designer is
figuring out how to take an idea and
actually make it in the most effective
way what does this look like when you're
using CAD and you're using all these
different tools to try and like simulate
adding doing this generator design
running what it would be like if it had
this or if it didn't have that what the
cost does how the all the different
engineering variables how those get
tweaked teach us about this so from
engineering perspective like when I was
designing in CAD the objective always
was to sort of design parts that meet
the basic specification of
functionalities so the basic
specification of functionality for a
suspension for example would be or take
an example of lower control arm should
be it should run at least a hundred
thousand miles with certain
specification or certain load cycles so
that was the engineering challenge that
I was trying to solve and I'm using a
very specific example but it is scalable
to any engineering design problem how do
I solve that challenge well I design a
part basically that fits within the
specification of the loading parameters
and then the next challenge is how do I
make it cost efficient so I have to
remove material so that it can be made
with the lightest possible weight it can
be made of the lightest possible weight
that still meets all the engineering
specification of running hundred
thousand cycles through different
loading parameters that's just the
engineering challenge of it then there
is supply chain challenge of it is how
do I sort of manufacture that part that
Blee for say 300 or 30,000 vehicles that
are going to be manufactured every month
so then there is a manufacturing cost
aspect to it then there is the assembly
is this design made for assembly where a
line personnel can take this part and
sort of fit it into the vehicle easily
then you have to sort of understand the
challenges of replacing it in field if
and there ever occurs a situation where
this part is under failure and it has to
be replaced so then all of these support
maintenance costing aspects have to be
sort of considered during the design
process early stage design process as
early as possible so that you don't have
to redesign parts further down into the
life cycle of the product so that's
those are the challenges that I wanted
to sort of conquer so to speak for lack
of a better term as quickly as possible
as early as possible so that I don't I
there is minimum amount of rework
required later in the validation stage
but as we said like there aren't sort of
tools baked into which will sort of
generate those design sort of what you
might say options opportunities will
give me sort of what different kind of
designs look like if you have different
kinds of challenges and that lack of
that tool kind of sort of brought me to
this long arduous journey that we've
sort of there is pretty much shaped my
entire adult life so to speak yeah now
okay so when you when you when you're
explaining this this this this you know
it almost it almost hurts a designer
engineer when something so far down the
road ends up yeah and you have to you
know redesign it and you're giving this
example of like something like
maintenance is it easy to maintain is it
easy to access in the assembly process
all of these questions can actually hit
these milestones that you're looking to
have it hit at the lowest weight and in
supply all the variables of the supply
chain so then how does with all these
variables at in in during to compute how
does how does the sigh are how do you
how does your software then make all
these kind of like simulations all these
computes four possibilities and then see
which ones are the best ones I'm gonna
start by saying we're not doing all of
that right now so we're starting at the
very beginning of that journey so that
is the end we're starting right now at
the very beginning which is how do you
design a part that that in fact how does
a a an engineer with an undergraduate
education who's less than a year from
graduation sit down at his or her desk
and design a part that has a very good
chance of being successful all the way
through the validation process so that's
the problem that we're solving right now
and as we evaluated and looked at all
the tools out there most of them need
more than a bachelor's degree to
actually use they're very expensive and
they're not integrated with the main
tool that that design engineer uses
which is his CAD program so the cat the
design engineer sitting at the CAD
program and you want them to be able to
generate ideas that have a much better
chance of being successful because every
iteration takes time and it's very
expensive and so that you you want that
design engineer to be able to explore
options very early in the process while
they're inside their CAD program so
they're not going back and forth between
different programs and that's the
problem we're trying to solve do you
want to that is an accurate assessment
that yes we're not trying to solve the
entire sort of value
not today not today version one is not
solving the entire sort of value chain
and sort of bringing everything into the
sort of design space exploration we are
specifically focused on some of the
early stage sort of design exploration
parameters so functionality is the key
parameter to a certain degree
manufacturability is another parameter
assembly is not sort of been sort of
used as a parameter yet costing of what
features to sort of replace add is not
sort of manufacturing costing is not
used as a parameter yet but sort of
functionality based on sort of
stiffnesses strengths frequencies part
consolidation that is baked into our
software as of today and and the idea is
sort of take all of those sort of
parameters functionalities and
constraints and provide a range of
designs like not just one design like
options you if you take all of those
sort of parameters and give you just one
design that's not really giving you
options like that's just telling you
well I think this design is good enough
that might still fail at validation but
that's kind of sort of is not it's
better than not using it at all but
still not sort of there from an early
stage design concept perspective so
we're trying to sort of provide multiple
designs each of which meet all of your
constraints to a different degree when
now the engineers can make those
decisions based on if one out of ten
part fails the validation test there are
still nine other options for you to try
which was still developed early enough
that you don't have to repeat the
process sequentially so we take a tool
we manufacture a tool that can then make
it easier for young people with just a
pretty solid couple years of engineering
experience to
able to then go and and design multiple
iterations of and use your platform for
the generator design with you then have
molted they have multiple iterations
let's say ten of these and so now do
they do they when they when so this is
this this works directly with their CAD
tool okay and then when when they're
let's take let's take apart what's a
common part for is it mostly automotive
is a common winner or a different
assembly robot or maybe so let's make it
easy okay it can be an automotive part
performance performance powertrain or
performance vehicle so think think
motorcycles racecars defense aerospace
and even handheld tools you know it
matters how like a drill it matters how
heavy it is so but but to make it easy
let's talk about a bracket okay and
let's talk about something that people
can kind of almost visualize the bracket
that attaches an airplane seat to the
floor okay so let's just use that as as
our example
okay now yes okay okay okay so we take
this this bracket that attaches the
airplane seat to the floor and now we're
basically we're trying to iterate on
that to make it more efficient more
cost-efficient potentially source to
materials from safer and more
ecologically friendly ways all these
different sorts of make the supply chain
easier so so then when we when we when
we have a student that's using CAD and
using your generative design software as
well then they get the they sort of make
a first do they sort of make a first
bracket an L bracket and then they kind
of see how you help them with the other
nine options and they kind of get to see
that and then tweak it together so you
have this C bracket okay and what do you
want as the passenger you want to know
in a really hard you know slowdown of
that airplane or really hard
acceleration
the bracket is going to hold tight okay
and so there are forces there's you have
to meet a certain you know like if you
have a really heavy passenger you don't
want the bracket to break
so there's weight forces there's
acceleration forces there's all kinds of
forces that that bracket has to
withstand in the space and then you've
got the space so what our software
allows you to do is create here's a
maximum space here's all the attachment
points okay and here's all the forces
that it needs to withstand and then you
hit a button and say go okay like like
literally yes okay so you have the space
you have the attachment locations and
you have the forces at play and then you
hit a button and then it simulates out
all of the different ways that it could
support that those forces and those
attachment points and with different
material so you're simulating on
different so so you do select the
material right so but but you can just
once you have all the force you can
rerun it with three or four different
materials if you wants you can explore
materials and and the design will look
different depending on what kind of
material you you use so so that will
give you a complete freedom design and
when I say freedom I'm talking about
manufacturing freedom and so that in
general will give you a design that
needs to be additively manufactured okay
so here's the thing over 90 percent of
over 95% of all manufacturing is still
traditionally manufactured so we also
allow you to put in a constraint that
says I have to be able to forge or cast
this design so that you actually can put
in manufacturing constraints rather than
just I have this really cool additive
additive part that has to run on an
additive manufacturing machine now
typically those manufacturing
constraints will make it heavier but
will be
a lot less expensive so in today's world
we're giving that engineer the chance to
select is it you know do you want to put
a manufacturing constraint in or not in
the future if we start rolling in this
is what a cost additively manufacture it
this is what would cost to to
traditionally manufacture it then it's
very likely that's a software will that
you can also then put in that cost
constraint and can generate here's the
lowest cost the lowest cost you know
aligned with the lowest weight but we're
not we're not at that point yet very
interesting a way to be able to add a
you know to if you're doing additive
manufacturing you're you're able to save
so much on on on on like an ecological
standpoint and and on a you know on a
way standpoint and all this other kind
of good stuff so adding that to the
equation sounds really important now
what if you if you walk us through this
this example after they've after they've
went and added all the constraints and
they've and they've went and simulated
out that maybe they've played with
different materials they've simulated
out again what would what would one do
with those these are now they have
different CAD files and then what would
they do with those would they try and
would they true what they they they will
have learned obviously quite a bit on
the different permutations that could
exist to fill the same need and then are
they kind of trying to maybe use that in
order to say you know hey Boeing I have
a pretty good way of looking at your
bracket that connects the sea to the to
the floor of the plane and and because
of that maybe I can get work with you or
we got what what would they do kind of
and then in the next steps it would have
certainly made my life easier
but yes like so it kind of sort of
enhances their capability to sort of
make design decision early stage without
relying on an expert analysis team to
sort of validate whether the designs are
a go or no-go at the very fundamental
level you want to figure out whether
these designs are going to work or not
work yes so the early stage design
concept so when we say we want to
generate smarter early stage design
concepts we want to eliminate all the
bad designs that are guaranteed not to
pass validation and then we want to
create enough options to explore the
validation step with the expert analysis
team the expert analysis team is going
to do a much more sort of involved
model-based system engineering analysis
to make sure that everything works is
fine they'll have far fewer sort of
concepts to play with which are at least
at the base level guaranteed to sort of
pass the functionality test that's very
very beautifully explained just that if
you get validated as well at a at your
first rid of all the bad designs that
aren't actually going to work in the in
the in the physical and the physical
reality that that's very very important
saves lots of time lots of resources it
get actually like we explaining just the
learning the learning side of it is is
so critical okay now now all right let's
let's play on this scenario a little bit
longer so the the what we have we have
these validated now generative designs
that have come out of this process
they're validated that's yes okay so I
want to make a nuance so the designs
that come out of this process are not
validated but what we've done is we've
taken the universe of designs that we
know are going to fail and we've taken
them out so there's a the nuance is that
you know we're not saying these are
validated
designs but we're saying we think
there's they're a lot closer to the
final design and that should eliminate
some of your your back-and-forth in
iteration as we went through this
process we talked to a lot of companies
and they would tell us that they would
have anywhere between six and ten
iterations between the analysts and the
design engineer to finally get a good
part and so from their perspective if
they can get down to two iterations that
is a huge time savings and even you know
and at the end many of these companies
are still using they're not just using
simulation to validate they're still
making parts and running them through a
a prototype validation phase and so if
you if you are closer to this the final
part you save a ton of money on
prototype parts and running them through
the validation phase because they can
get through that phase so there's still
a final validation you know final
simulation final validation that happens
but we've taken out a lot of the known
things that will fail through that
process okay yeah that was great nuance
awesome
okay so then so then we're a big part of
sigh art is then to be able to move all
of the designs that are being made
towards the direction of success towards
the direction of validation and in that
direction at least and and and and
through that process saving people time
money resources all that stuff now yeah
because you're given you're given all
these constraints like you said with the
forces and the and the look index and
the size and the material in that way it
if you're going outside of those
constraints then there are some
potentially creative solutions that the
Brat yeah that could be outside of those
parameters that then would need to be
you know explored with the final valid
validation process of maybe this is
potentially better so how does let's see
if we can
you explained on that on the technical
side how the how does this how does your
software work with the initial design in
CAD to make the additional like nine
let's say cads so our software is what
we call is add add in it adds into the
CAD tool and as an input from a CAD
software we only require the initial
representation of the geometry like the
boundary you just have to specify what
your boundaries of your design space are
going to look like and then the add-in
like our tool sort of provides you those
many option as any other menu option
that you would see within those CAD
tools using those menu options now you
set up the problem to run on the back
end our software that runs right within
their ecosystem it runs seamlessly on
their workstation without sort of them
having to sort of do any kind of a file
exchange between one system and the
other system so to engineer it would
appear that the tools were available as
an option within the CAD program so they
just have to learn another menu but the
way the tool behaves is still the same
like the designs that are generated
they're generated within their workspace
in addition to this add-in component you
said that there's the the the outlining
the geometries of where the design needs
to be in the in the in the digital 3d
space then how how do you then let's
talk about this how do you you know you
have this like there's forces then
there's the locations right where it
needs to be so so then they would you
you would you or your add-in would then
also add those variables and then your
add-in would compute the alternative
designs
so our add-in gives the engineer to add
in those variables so how many is so
remind me how many different constraints
can an engineer put in on one design so
constraints and functionalities I sort
of make a distinction on that so from a
functionality standpoint there are
quantitative sort of constraints let's
call them quantitative constraints that
you have to put such as forces that the
design has to support restraints on the
surfaces maintaining certain surfaces
for say assemblies or sort of spot
checks maintaining the references or
retaining boundaries like an other set
of constraints that sort of yield what
we call is stresses your displacement
and so it's a frequency variables so
these are quantitative constraints like
you can measure them you have to run a
simulation and then you have to measure
all of those constraints then there are
qualitative constraints which do not
require simulation like they require a
ray-tracing check whereas the
accessibility of the feature for example
so for casting you cannot add feature in
a direction where it is inaccessible to
the cast because you have to pour the
material and then you have to sort of be
molded so like those are qualitative
constraints maintaining Zoar extrude
directions
let's qualitative constraints you don't
have specifically run a simulation to
sort of add those constraints but when
you're removing material based on the
simulation you have to be cognizant of
those qualitative constraints symmetry
is another qualitative constraint so
maintain symmetry about a plane sort of
axial symmetry radial symmetry those are
additional constraints so all of these
are sort of provided as input using our
tools sort of to list or what your menu
options that show up within the cad
platform that interact with the part
while that is still sitting inside the
card sort of software yes
all right so how many external
constraints so forces restraints how
many can I do can I do three can I do
for how many can I how many can I put in
yes so that really depends on how many
you want to like we can if you want ten
different sort of constraints based on
your loads we can do ten if you have
hundred constraints we can do hundred it
basically sort of comes down to how much
time do you want to wait and how much
computer resources do you have exactly
so it's it's if you have uncertain like
if you want to sort of granular really
sort of map out a dynamic system sort of
for a complete 360 degree cycle say a
one full revolution would be like 360
degree cycle and you want to do it like
at every degree you can set in 360
constraints and to manage all of those
constraints to do your design
exploration do you usually have the
computation done on the local machine or
do you send off the computation it's
always on the local machine so ideally
our philosophy is that the computer
resources that you have are sufficient
to run complex real life problems like
the simulation are simple from a
simulation capability like we are able
to sort of simulate all of these
different designs within your system and
that's that's part of our secret sauce
is that you don't have to be connected
to the cloud so from you know because of
my GM background his his Tata Motors
background we both come from large
enterprise backgrounds and right now
they're they they don't want their data
going into the cloud now that may change
in the future but where that where where
where those companies are right now
and we've talked to really hundreds of
engineers who are like oh you're doing
generative design and then we say and it
all runs on your laptop oh I want to
talk to you because they have already
been told their designs are not going up
into the cloud and so that's that's a
non-starter for for many of the people
companies that that would be interested
in this yeah yeah that's this very good
point at the same time it's also
interesting to you know as we were just
discussing that if you're computing
three variables it can potentially be
done locally if you're maybe doing a
hundred it might not be able to compute
locally this may be this may take too
long of a processor it may be done much
faster if it's done with a more powerful
machine this type of these types of
points now then is it then your your
proprietary algorithms do the
computations of the restraints of the
constraints the functionalities that are
that are needed
that's what SCI art software is doing
yes so they are doing all of those
computations of sort of simulating all
these restraints all these constraints
designed by design locally and so it
Matt so let's throw a hypothetical like
you're doing three different scenarios
three different constraint scenarios and
you're solving for say 80% material
removal and you would like to explore
every design for like 2% material for
every two person material removal you
want to see what the design looks like
so we are performing the simulation
three times every 2% material removal
all the ways that are removing 80% so
they'll fail
because yeah yeah yeah maybe maybe then
what you're trying to do then is your
your room is this the case you're trying
to remove the amount of materials by two
percent until you get a failure and then
you know what the minimum amount of
material you need is for the one hundred
thousand uses or whatever yeah that's
exactly yeah okay oh that's so
interesting that seems like exactly what
we need to instead of like you said this
now becomes more about science and the
simulations and knowing that the truth
and versus subjectively taking guesses
or having to do things long-form
computations and it works to have a tool
that can just simulate these out much
faster do you then then do you have that
you have like an algorithm then that
does that actual like decrease by two
percent and then check that's so
interesting that's so cool do you have
more examples like that where you're
like decreasing something like a
material by two percent or that you're
all of our examples are like that so any
design exploration that we do we do it
so the parameters is like what is the
volume that you want to decrease every
step and the parameters are what are the
constraints that you're applying beyond
that you can choose to remove material
all like 99% of the material it's not
going to go that would be another
example with maybe one of the messing
around with another one of the variables
like the forces or the attachment points
you know do you are those are those four
I mean like are those a forever
constraint or can they be creatively you
know run permutations to creatively
figure out how to make it better so
manufacturing constraints adding
manufacturing constraints will give you
different results after every two-person
material removal adding
say frequency like so if you're
optimizing for frequency the designs
that will be generated for every two
person material removal we are going to
look wildly different then if you're
optimizing for strength or if you're
optimizing for stiffness so each of
these kind of sort of driving parameters
can give you different exotic designs
and all of those exotic designs are sort
of generated step-by-step so remove
material cycle through all the
constraints that you have figure out
which is the constraint that is closest
to failure and then let that be the
dictating constraint for material
removal for the next step so it
automatically sort of switches between
which constraints are important and also
automatically sort of sometimes it sort
of takes too big a step and it fails and
it comes back and it sees like if there
is another direction that it can sort of
go to and sort of remove any more
material without sort of violating any
of those constraints so it does all of
those adaptive sort of decision-making
from an algorithm standpoint based on
the number of constraints that you've
specified you add more constraints you
get different designs you reduce some
number of constraints and you sort of
give it more freedom to explore even
further that was not able to sort of it
wasn't able to reach because those
constraints were valid in previous
iterations so that this is basically
having me realize that all of these ways
that we're enhancing the the human
design and engineering process is very
beautiful and important but at the same
time it's making me realize that soon it
will be able to do this on its on its
own process and that will see how long
that actually ends up taking and stuff
but for now a little enhanced and that
may happen a long time down the road but
there's so and what I'm gonna tell you
is there's so many things that I need to
happen
to get to that point okay
and and at the end of the day you know
working for GM what are we focused on
eliminating waste out of the process
right and I was in the manufacturing
operations and so the goal Toyota
Production system we implemented that at
GM and it's all about Olympian waste is
included in standing when you're not
working it's it's it's throwing things
away that you shouldn't have to throw
away I mean there's a lot of different
kinds of waste as part of that process
and what what we would both tell you is
there is a ton of waste when you have a
design engineer do something and then
have to wait so waste waiting is waste
okay have to wait someone else analyzes
it comes back and says this failed and
and can't even necessarily tell you why
it failed so you take another guess go
back forth back forth so you know the
first part of this process is how do you
eliminate waste in in in that process
now the future we talked about you
talked about the future we are in
violent agreement about the long term
future but but the you know AI I mean we
know it's like a human can look at
something to say oh there's a problem
here and that it's a long way away
before that comes out of the design
process because that experience of you
know I look at it oh that won't work but
if we just adjust it a little bit maybe
this will work but but this kind of
software will give you options that the
human brain because it just hasn't even
thought about yeah we have to sleep and
we have to I mean it's just you know
it's some of these solutions you look at
them and you're like wow where did that
come from
yeah yeah teach us about saiyr
software's you know next steps right now
it's the add-in on the CAD when what is
the next thing is the next thing also
the ability to do some of these
simulations with the supply chain or
with or with the with with that with
down the line with the actual process of
how difficult it will be to do
maintenance where did where the next
parts of the so so current step is with
design engineers and a lot of doing
traditional manufacturing so next step
is taking this super fast on the desktop
capability to do design for additive
manufacturing all right and I'm gonna
let you talk a little more about that so
most of the manufacturing process that
we've sort of used as a constraint up
until now are kind of qualitative
manufacturing process like we have some
information based on the visual of what
a part looks like and those
manufacturing processes based on those
visual information and some tabulated
information we sort of enforce those as
constraints additive manufacturing is a
whole different beast altogether like
the process itself has to be simulated
and that simulated process will give you
information about the physics of the
part that comes out because of the
process like the process itself changes
the material behavior of the part that
is being sort of created through a in
process so just to be able to sort of
get a initial sort of process simulation
done and then bake that into design
decision tree to sort of generate
designs that are now going to be more
likely to succeed
through the a.m process and will retain
the functionality that you design those
parts to sort of maintain in the first
place is going to within the next step
so understanding the am awareness of the
design is what we're looking at then
with give us with the bracket we were
talking about what would that look like
with the the second step of that am
so assuming that the assuming that the
first step with that bracket we said it
needs to be manufactured traditionally
well with AM and and and I'm now talking
specifically metal am if you have angles
you have a you build it a certain way
and against the build direction so the Z
height of the build direction if you
have an angle greater than 45 degrees
you need to design supports okay so you
can picture I need to do this and the
way you set up your build will actually
determine what your design needs to look
like so you've got your process
awareness and then there's going to be
issues around well gee how many are you
going to build on a build plate and the
the heat interaction will create
potential for warping and so taking all
of those build things and putting it
into your design software and figuring
out not how to do it in the cloud but to
how to do it on your desktop and that's
our that's our next next version and
then as a wrap let's think on with all
of the different transitions that are
happening on there like them this
massive technological and economic
revolution that's going on in terms of
the Exponential's where do you see the
most amount of both of sayare software
being able to make an impact as well as
your specific most interest in what's
going on with the exponential tech are
you're gonna make me answer that one
aren't you
so we so there's a couple things one is
the the huge expansion of metal 3d
printing is going to just fundamentally
change the way Mechanical Engineers
design parts okay and the question is
when do you how when do you start
getting mechanical engineers thinking
about designing parts functionally
versus sit down and draw and and we
think we're the right tool for today to
do that but the future and I'm gonna I'm
gonna actually I'm gonna talk about a
vision that Joe Walsh shared with me
which is picture that in the very early
that that all parts are essentially
designed functionally and today we think
about here's a model and this is what
you build so you build it in prototype
you build it in production and you build
it for service but if you picture the
future is we need something that does X
and you have a functional build and you
validate the X in prototype and then you
move into high-volume production and the
part looks completely different even
though it has the exact same functional
capability and you you you build it one
way in production and then as you get
down and and and the part is in a
vehicle that's 20 years old and it's
it's more towards the end of its service
life but it breaks on a vehicle and you
need to replace it you may have a third
design that meets the same functional
requirements but it looks very different
than the part that it's replacing and
that is that is the promise of
generative design is that that it's not
the part itself that's so important
as opposed to the function of what this
part does all the way through the
long-term life of that product and so it
ties into the digital thread it ties
into it ties into the digital twins it
ties into a lot of the industry 4.0 but
the ultimate vision is that design will
start identifying here's the function it
doesn't matter what it looks like Wow
yeah damn that's cool yeah if we're
designing with the intent of
functionality as the foremost importance
and then just let all the permutations
run and see what ends what it ends up
being as the most solid one that's
really cool yeah and then that skips out
on all of the time that we spend on on
potentially the bad designs and yeah
very cool very cool
any thoughts Praveen on the last
question well I want to build a Dyson
Sphere long term vision not for the
company but in general is
self-replicating am processes where am
machines are building more a machines
they are building parts that will go and
sort of propagate the structures that
need to be built before a human can ever
sort of go into that space thinking from
a space exploration standpoint yeah but
that's a different story altogether
I am gonna say something here also which
is this is an exciting time but it's
also a scary time right because it's
like we don't know what that means to
our society we don't know what that
vision means to our culture our society
and
just what people are going to do in the
future but but you know when you moved
from you know a predominantly
agricultural situation with the seem
engine they didn't know either and there
will clearly be people displaced and you
know so for me personally it doesn't
mean I have I walk away I worry about
how do we societally deal with this
displacement okay and all the technology
that's coming that are gonna displace
people who have good solid middle-class
jobs I don't know where this is going
but I also know that you cannot stand in
the way of where technology wants to
take you and so we're going down this
path because the technology's gonna go
whether we whether we do it or someone
else the future I absolutely believe and
in his description that is going to be
the future so it's going to happen but
but you know being being aware of that
and at least trying to understand that
this isn't just about the company this
is about the greater what happens in the
world and wanting to be aware and care
about that that would be my final
messages it's not it's it's not just
about the one thing it's like there's
there's ramifications to us as a society
in a global society and I hope that the
people who are watching this are aware
of that also yeah this is a very good
way to wrap I am very much in agreeance
I think there's mostly a retraining
issue that we're facing I think there's
gonna be a significant amount of jobs
that open up as well in coding in the
IOT world and all these interesting
fascinating slots but that how do we
retrain people that were driving trucks
or cabs how do we retrain service retail
industry people to want maybe augmented
reality maybe some
has to do with the brain computer
interface world who knows but I think
that it is definitely one of the big
problems but it's a it's also a very
interesting vision of additive
manufacturing making more additive
manufacturing that runs the permutations
it makes the best functionality pieces
and the limited slots that it can fit in
this is a very very cool conversation
I'm very happy that sire it's at the
frontier of being able to push into this
because it's saves bad does the saves
time away from bad designs moves us
towards the the right designs for at
younger ages for kids to be able to go
through this process young adults can
get in through this process faster
thanks a lot for coming on to the show
you too thank you so much we really
appreciate this was a lot of fun yeah
thank you so much we really appreciate
everyone for tuning in thank you so much
we would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below let us know what
you're thinking about about generative
design and also give give sigh are to
check check out their link in the bio
below and support the artisan
entrepreneurs that you believe in
support simulation all of our links are
below check out co fest support co Fez
their links are below as well and go and
build the future manifest your dreams
into the world everyone we love you very
much thanks for tuning in and we will
see you soon peace